ابنيه قائمه لكن الى متى دمر الزلزال
سوريا وتركيا الاف الابنيه واستوت بالارض
لكن القائم منها ايضا تصدع وبات ايلا
للسقوط في اي لحظه
لم يتشرد فقط من فقدوا منازلهم بل ايضا
اولئك الخائفون من العوده الى ابنيه
انتشرت في دعاماتها الشروخ وتتمايل من اي
هزه ارتداديه
من سكان مدينه انطاكيا والتي تضررت بشكل
كبير من الزلزال لجات مع زوجها واطفالها
الى مبنى في حديقه ورغم ان منزلها لم يسقط
الا انها تريد المغادره والاستقرار في
مكان امن
نريد المغادره فقدت اربعه من افراد عائلتي
نجا ثلاثه اشقاء فقط نحن عالقونا هنا ولا
يوجد احد لا اعرف كيف سنغادر
رعب وحزن لم يقتصر على من فقدوا احبتهم
ومسكنهم بل حاله عامه سكنت قلوبك كل من
شهد الكارثه التي هزت المنطقه على نطاق
واسع
اعتقدنا في البدايه انه تم تدمير ثلاث او
خمسه مباني فقط وعندما اشرقت الشمس ادركنا
حجم الزلزال وعندها فقط فهمنا الموقف
تراني لا ثالث لهما امام السكان المناطق
المنكوبه اما المغادره بحثا عن مامن من
الخطر المستمر منذ اسبوع او البقاء بين
الانقاض بانتظار منازل لن تعود على الاقل
في المدى القريب
وكلاهما فيه تشرد ينتظر المنكوبين حتى
اشعار اخر
اذا عمر العربيه